[Music]
fired up
[Music]
smart kicks it out
and jalen brown knocks down the
three-pointer shot
koine
goes up leans in and that's what they're
not calling this year
when the player leans in like that as
brown goes coast to coast count it and a
foul
walker tried to draw the charge because
this is a big swing that's three free
throws if you get the call you don't you
complain sprint back
celtics do a great job led by brown of
putting it
well i thought i think they're going to
miss reggie bullock in the regular
season i thought he was terrific last
year jalen brown has scored the last 11
points for the celtics four for five
from the field fires again and connects
and it shows you the great the
growth of jason tatum brown rolling
allows him to handle the basketball and
initiate the option marcus smart tries
at three
and how important brown would play a
role for this celtic team got it going
smith
[Music]
round
talk about putting pressure on the
defense so powerful avoid the contact
and the play before against rose pretty
good individual defense but just bigger
what a start for jalen brown final
minute here in the first
randall turns it over
knee smith the head to brown goes inside
lay up shots cut and the foul by randall
leads to this and just a beautiful
finish by jalen brown
[Applause]
[Music]
berks on brown
jalen brown tough turnaround shot making
him look easy jaylen brown 22 points
eight of ten from the field
everybody talks about
you know him slowing down
i thought last year he had a great burst
he still has a great burst and jalen
brown
still has it dialed in on autumn
walker gets inside shot blocked brown
comes up with it
[Applause]
jalen brown stutter dribble back up top
to tatum
has some room connects on a three he was
over seven from downtown but nails that
one and the celtics go up by now
richardson one of the new acquisitions
he's got a migraine couldn't play
tonight
wins to brown brown turnaround jumper
but he is so impressive
their lottery pick
from 2020.
jalen brown a three got it naylan brown
from downtown they have really struggled
from three
derrick rose that's how you apologize
get the three back
brown splits the defense surrounded by
nixon still scores his handle has
improved so much
jason tatum
trying to find the rhythm
brown nearly knocked away kicks it out
in the corner grant williams puts it in
grant williams his third three-pointer
of the fourth quarter and it's a
five-point game boy good ball denial
fournier trying to get to it brown
knocks it off and goes out of bounds
celtic ball
what a play from jalen brown and boston
gets it r.j barrett on jalen brown
taking up a lot of time
round the crossover around the drive
inside lays it up and in it's a
three-point game
brown comes free
fournier on him throws up a long
three-pointer oh it's good jalen brown
drills it with 5.3 remaining and you saw
it coming the pin down he catches it
good job extending him and then you give
him the air space to elevate that's a
tough shot but a big shot
jaylen brown has been hot all night long
jalen brown jason tatum robert williams
and dennis schroeder rounds sets fires
and hits a three
42 points on opening night for jalen
brown
tatum to shreder
back to tatum double team brown extra
pass smart one or three got it
everybody knocking down threes
here later the garden robert williams
has won both overtime tips
jalen brown kicks it out smart back to
brown brown has a good look fires away
knocks it down
46 points for jalen brown
and that's what robinson does so very
well as brown
[Music]